Bitte schön. Guten Abend.
Hallo, guten Abend.
Hallo, ich heiße Foukambaran, bin auf dieser Station als...
Wir heißen Sie bitte.
Foukambaran.
Was ist das für ein komischer Name? Tut mir leid, ich verstehe das nicht.
Willkommen.
Das ist keinem... keine wichtige Thema.
Also wir sind hier als Professionellarzt gearbeitet.
Deswegen...
Ich habe Ihre Namen leider nicht ganz verstanden.
Foukambaran.
Ist man...
Baran.
Ja, genau.
Doktor Baran, okay, bitte schön.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Dienstabender.
Ist schon lange hier in Deutschland.
Wo kommen Sie her, Doktor?
Ja, bitte.
Ich brauche keine Unterbrechung.
Lassen Sie uns als Erste diese Aufnahme, diese Gespräche,
wendeführen.
Damit hätte ich Ihre alle Fragen beantworten.
Ich glaube, ich...
Ich habe keine Sorge.
Kann ich zu, Herr Doktor? Tut mir leid.
Wenn ich als Patient hier bei Ihnen bin, dann müssen Sie mir zuhören, Herr Doktor.
Sie können mich doch nicht unterbrechen.
Dann möchte ich einen anderen Arzt sprechen, bitte.
Ja.
Leider nur...
Leider nur bin ich hier als Dienstabender.
Wir haben keine andere Arzt.
Wenn Sie andere Arzt möchten,
sollten Sie andere Krankenhauten...
Ich seh, bitte, dass Sie mir auch zuhören, Herr Doktor,
wenn ich zu Ihnen spreche.
Und bitte unterbrechen Sie mich nicht.
Ich höre Sie so.
Bitte.
Danke schön.
Herr Doktor Baran, bitte.
Ich würde gerne diese Aufnahme mit Ihnen durchführen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Sylvia.
Und Ihre Nachname?
Mein Nachname ist Geisler.
Geisler. Können Sie Ihre Vorname und Nachname postabieren?
Also Sylvia, wie man es ausspricht, Siegfried Y, Ludwig, Vogelv, Ida Anton,
und Geisler Gustav Emil Ida,
Doppels Ludwig Emil Richard.
Okay.
Frau Geisler, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 42 Jahre alt.
Warum wurden Sie geboren?
Am 28.08.1982.
Nee, 84.
84, okay.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ungefähr 65 Kilo.
Und wie groß sind Sie, Frau Geisler?
1 Meter 63.
63, okay.
Und haben Sie einen Hausarzt oder Hausärztin?
Das ist Dr. Frank in Hütztenhausen.
Ja, ich kenne ihn.
Er ist sehr gut erst.
Sehr gut. Ja, das stimmt.
Er ist leider in Urlaub, deswegen muss ich jetzt Sie herkommen, sonst werde ich zu ihm gegangen.
Okay, ich verstehe Sie.
Was hat Sie sonst geführt, Frau Geisler?
Ich habe seit 2 Tagen zunehmende Unterbaubschmerzen.
Das ist immer schlimmer geworden.
Okay.
Seit 2 Tagen haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Ja, das wird immer schlimmer, wäre ich nicht gekommen.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Ja, ich habe sie nicht beschrieben.
Was können Sie sagen?
Ich habe es sehr langsam angefangen.
Ich dachte, das ist jetzt nichts Spezielles.
Aber es ist innerhalb von, seit gestern hat es sehr, sehr stark zugenommen.
Es ist ja mal sehr stark, krampfartig, mal dumpf.
Dann strahlt es auch ein bisschen in die Leiste aus.
Die Schmerzen sind sehr stark.
Ich habe Schmerztablette genommen, aber das hat ich mir nicht geholfen.
Was haben Sie eingenommen?
Ich mag nicht so viele Tabletten.
Deswegen habe gestern Abend eine Parazitamol genommen.
Aber das hat Ihnen nicht geholfen, oder?
Kaum.
Ich wollte jetzt nicht mehr nehmen, deswegen bin ich zu Ihnen gekommen.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10,
wenn 1 leichter und 10 unerträgliche Schmerzen sind?
Was können Sie sagen?
Heute Abend, zwischen 6 und 8.
6 und 8.
Sie haben schon gesagt, die Schmerzen strahlen in die Leiste aus.
Sehr diffus, ich kann es nicht genau zuordnen.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass sie eher im Unterbauch in der Mitte ist,
um die Blase herum irgendwo ist.
Sie können mich ja nachher mal angucken.
Ich denke, dass sie auch in die rechte Leiste etwas auskommt.
Wir befinden sich in der Mitte, oder?
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass es mehr in der Mitte ist.
Okay.
Und gibt es etwas, haben Sie eine Auslöser bemerkt?
Nein, das war alles in Ordnung.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Das kam ganz plötzlich.
Ich kann es nicht sagen.
Ich war jetzt nicht verreist.
Sie haben gesagt, dass diese Schmerzen langsam begonnen haben.
Aber plötzlich begonnen, sagten Sie nun.
Also mit plötzlich, meine ich, es gab keine Auslöser.
Es hat einfach so.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und gibt es etwas, was diese Schmerzen verstärkt oder lindert?
Nein, kann ich nicht sagen.
Also das ist mal mehr, mal weniger.
Aber heute ist es, um auszuhalten.
Hatten Sie solche Beschwerden schon einmal?
Nein, so stark nicht.
Ich habe immer wieder mal ein bisschen Bauchschmerzen.
Da habe ich mal Durchfall gehabt oder ein bisschen Blähung.
Aber das ist jetzt echt, das ist etwas anderes.
Nun haben Sie schon Blähungen und Durchfall?
Durchfall habe ich jetzt nicht, aber ich habe das Gefühl,
ich habe viel Luft im Bauch.
Okay.
Und haben Sie sonst noch etwas bemerkt, oder?
Nein, das sind wie gesagt die Schmerzen.
Sie fühlen sich in Ihrer Bauchübeblähung also.
Und Sie leiden unter Durchfall, wenn ich Sie richtig verstanden habe, oder?
Kein Durchfall.
Das war früher immer wieder, wenn ich Bauchschmerzen hatte.
Jetzt habe ich keinen Durchfall.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, es ist ein bisschen komisch vielleicht,
aber ansonsten nicht.
Vielleicht ist es ziehen,
aber Schmerzen habe ich keine beim Wasserlassen.
Keine Probleme beim Wasserlassen.
Okay.
Und wie verhalten sich diese Schmerzen,
wenn Sie sitzen oder wenn Sie stechen
oder wenn Sie laufen?
Das kann ich nicht sagen.
Es gibt keine Situation, wo es besser wird.
Wenn ich sitze, habe ich das Gefühl,
es wird noch schlimmer.
Haben Sie Fieber, Frau Geisler?
Bisher noch nicht, aber ich habe es auch nicht gemessen,
weiß ich nicht.
Haben Sie diese Schmerzen verlagert?
Nein, das ist immer im Unterbauch verlagert.
Im Unterbauch.
Und als letztes,
wann haben Sie zum Toilettegegern
für Sturgang oder?
Das war gestern Arbeit.
Gestern Abend.
Gibt es ein Problem?
Da war jetzt nichts Auffälliges.
Haben Sie ein Brüttelmärkt in Ihrer Stuhl vielleicht?
Nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Okay.
Und wie ist der Appetit, Frau Geisler?
Seit zwei Tagen weniger,
als ich habe auch heute kam gegessen,
ich habe keinen Appetit.
Warum haben Sie keinen Appetit?
Weiß ich nicht.
Wie können diese Schmerzen vielleicht?
Keine Ahnung.
Das müssen Sie mir sagen, Herr Dr.
Okay.
Und haben Sie in der letzten Seite ab oder zu genommen?
Nein.
Und wie ist dir Schlau?
Das ist in Ordnung.
Ja, jetzt seit zwei Tagen mit den Schmerzen
und ich würde auch in der Nacht ab und zu mal wachten.
Das stimmt wegen den Schmerzen.
Aber ansonsten ist es bisher immer normal gewesen.
Und müssen Sie in der Nacht zum Toilette gehen?
Nein.
Was lassen?
Schwitzen Sie in der Nacht?
Nein.
Sind Ihnen Saures aufstoßen?
Ist Ihnen Saures aufstoßen, aufgefallen?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Oder ist Ihnen übel?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Und Sie haben keine Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Ich wollte mich nur ablesen.
Nein, nein.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Geschlechtswerk?
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich wohne im Moment allein, ich habe keinen Partner.
Das Problem habe ich nicht.
Frau Geisler, leiden Sie an irgendeine wöchentliche Erkrankung?
Zum Beispiel Zuckerkrankheit, Bruthoffdruck oder schildrössener Erkrankungen?
Nein, bisher habe ich nichts.
Ich nehme auch keine chronischen Medikamente ein.
Und wurden Sie schon einmal operär, bislang stationär behandelt?
Nein, bisschen noch nicht.
Nehmen Sie irgendeine medikamente regelmäßig ein?
Nein.
Und haben Sie Allergien oder Unferziglichkeiten?
Allergien habe ich jetzt nicht, aber früher sind einige Pollen, wo ich ein bisschen allergisch reagiere, aber ansonsten nichts.
Wie haben Sie sich damals ausser?
Was meinen Sie, was äußern?
Wie reagieren Sie sich, wenn Sie eine Pollenallergie haben?
Mir läuft die Nase ein bisschen und ich kriege etwas Tränen in den Augen und dann nehme ich eine Zettirizid und dann hilft das ganz gut.
Und trauen Sie, Frau Geister?
Auch nicht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol, Alkohol, sehr selten, ab und zu, aber ansonsten nicht.
Was trinken Sie und in welcher Zeitraum?
Ich, wenn ich mal unterwegs bin oder auch fest, dann trinke ich mal ein Verein oder so, aber mehr nicht.
Ein Glas oder?
Ja, ganz wenig Glas.
Und Frau Geister, bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie schon einmal Drogen probiert oder konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Als Studentin habe ich mal ein bisschen etwas probiert, aber das war jetzt nur auf Spaß, aber ich nehme normalerweise keine Drogen.
Was haben Sie damals probiert?
Das waren das Äxte Sie, Marihuana, das war es.
Das war sehr gute Entscheidung, also mit dem Drogen aufzuhören.
Und treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, ich gehe regelmäßig Sport, ich mache Fitness, ich mache Yoga und ich spiele Volleyball.
Volleyball, okay.
Und Sie haben keine Partner, das Sie haben?
Nein, wirklich nicht.
Und bekommen Sie Ihre Monatspilotung regelmäßig oder?
Ja, da gibt es keine Probleme mehr.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Was machen Sie als Beruf?
Ich bin Geschäftsführerin einer kleinen Firma.
Und haben Sie viel Stress bei der Arbeit?
Ja, das ist manchmal schon sehr schlimm, aber im Moment geht es eigentlich.
Aktuell ist es nicht so schlimm.
Und leben Ihre Eltern noch, Frau Geister?
Ja, ja, sie sind gesund.
Die gehen gut.
Und leiden Ihre Eltern an urgentbärische krankungen?
Ja, also so weit ich weiß nicht, dass sie relativ fit sind.
So weit ich weiß, haben sie nichts. Glücklicherweise bisher noch nichts.
Okay, sehr gut.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe nur noch ein Bruder.
Und ist der Bruder gesund?
Der hat glaube ich einen hohen Blutdruck ein bisschen,
aber der Mars ist beim Arzt, aber ich weiß nicht, ob er Medikamente nimmt.
Okay, sehr gut.
Und Frau Geister, wenn ich Sie richtig verstanden habe,
haben Sie seit zwei Tagen zunehmend Unterbauchschmerzen
mit Ausstrahlung in die Leiste.
Und diese Schmerzen haben Sie
von der Schmerzskala 6 bis 8 von 10 eingeschätzt.
Und Sie klagen über nur Überbläubungen, oder?
Ja, und ich habe das Gefühl, da ist viel Luft drin.
Und Sie haben keine Probleme beim Wasserlassen und mit dem Stullgang.
Okay.
Okay, wir sind am Ende dieses Gespräch.
Ich werde Sie jetzt körperlich untersuchen, dann Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Wir sollen ein, als erstes sollen wir eine Bauchultraschall durchführen,
dann vielleicht sollen wir eine Röntgen durchführen.
Ich werde mit meinem Oberarzt über Ihre Fall sprechen,
dann werde ich Sie gleichzeitig informieren.
Okay, ja, vielen Dank. Machen Sie das alles heute noch?
Ja, alles werde heute geschägen.
Also, möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen, oder haben Sie eine Frage?
Vielen Dank. Ich wäre froh, wenn Sie mir sagen, was es ist.
Es macht mir so langsam ein bisschen Sorgen und Kopfschmerzen,
oder Kopfzerbrechen.
Kopfzerbrechen, was meinen Sie?
Es macht mir Gedanken. Ich möchte wissen,
so langsam bekomme ich Angst.
Okay, machen Sie sich keine Sorgen bitte.
Sie sind in der Krankenhaus nun, also das war sehr gut entschieden.
Also Sie haben erstes schon sehr gut gemacht.
Wir werden alles schnell machen, machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Das wäre sehr schön. Vielen Dank.
Bitte sehr.
Ich habe eine sehr gute Anliegen.
Legen Sie sich auf die Begibt.
Okay, jetzt die Untersuchungsergebnisse.
Starke Druckschmerzen, rechter Unterbau.
Links, Loslassschmerz.
Labor, CRP von 160.
160.
160, okay.
Leuchtozytten, Blutbild, alles in Ordnung.
Nierenwerte, Leberwerte, auch in Ordnung.
Schildrösenwerte auch.
Im Ultraschall viel Luft.
Ansonsten alles unauffällig, sieht man nix.
Kein Nierenaufstau, keine Gallenblasensteine.
Und ja, das war es.
Okay.
Abunkollegen oder Kollegen, eine andere Frage.
Aber erst etwas sagen, hocam.
Bitte schön.
Hurkan, hier ist nicht Türkei.
Als können wir unsere Patienten nicht wie als Chef oder Patron behandeln.
Wir müssen unsere Patienten eine freundlich und klare Erklärung geben.
Sie sind nicht in der Einzige als in Deutschland.
Und der Patient hat in Deutschland das Recht, eine Arzt zu wählen.
Deswegen alle Krankenhaus, wenn die Patienten nicht ausmachen,
andere Arzt suchen muss.
Wenn sie diese Anfangs-Springen kann, dann tschüss.
Okay, das ist nicht gut Reaktion.
Bitte wieder.
Also ich habe es einmal gehört, aber ich konnte nicht ganz verstehen.
Ich soll diese Patienten verlassen oder?
Patient, das heißt Patient.
Deswegen sehr höflich behandeln müssen.
Diese Reaktion ist nicht gut.
Was soll ich machen, wenn Sie ein Beispiel geben?
Ich habe etwas gehört dafür.
Wir können sagen, Sie können Ihren Arzt natürlich wählen.
Aber leider sind alle meine Kollegen momentan besetzt.
Deswegen muss ich sie untersuchen.
Aber wenn Sie warten möchten, können Sie einfach da warten.
Ich habe es so gehört.
Herr Bader, Herr Doktor Badan hat nur am Anfang nur geredet und hat den Patienten nicht zugehört.
Das wollte ich ein bisschen bemerken.
Er hat sich danach noch mal korrigiert und hat auch gesagt,
okay, ich muss zuhören.
Sie können auch gerne zu einem anderen Arzt und er ist alleine.
Wenn die Patienten etwas fragen, dann sollte man auch den Patienten zuhören
und die Möglichkeit geben, dass sie aussprechen und nicht gleich unterbrechen.
Können wir als Arzt beginnen?
Gerne.
Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Keine Fragen.
Ich gehe in den Übel.
Nein, das habe ich nicht gebrochen.
Hast du die ähnliche Bescheidung?
Nein.
Das hat der Doktor schon gefragt.
Okay, dann machen wir weiter.
Hallo Herr Oberarzt, ich habe einen neuen Patienten angenommen.
Haben Sie seitensatz?
Ich bin gerne. Was haben Sie dabei?
Frau Silvia Geist, da ist eine 47-jährige Patientin,
die sich heute Abend bei uns wegen seit zwei Tagen
Bestehende, Sunneimende erst malig aufgetretene,
kramfartige Dunka unter Bauchschmerzen,
unter Abdominalschmerzen mit Ausstrahlung in die Lande.
Welche Lande?
In der Mitte, sagt Sumi aber.
Rechte.
Also in den Unterbauch und rechte Lande.
Das ist die Zeit, die mit das diese Schmerzen 6 bis 8
von 10 auf der Schmerzskala zahlen.
Diese Schmerzen hätten langsam begonnen
und seit gestern schlimm zahlen, seit gestern schlimm angeworden.
Außerdem habe ich sie ein Parasitomol Tablette eingenommen,
aber das könne ihr ja nicht geholfen.
Das habe ich ja nicht geholfen?
Das habe ich ja nicht geholfen.
Und verheiratete Patienten, die nach Flatulenz
als Begleitssymptome aufgefallen
und die Vegetation.
Flatulenz ist ja etwas anderes.
Wenn die Gase abgehen,
das ist Flatulenz in der Volkssprache Haag-Tlele 14.
Sie hat keine Flatulenz, sie hat Blähungen.
Methorismus?
Das ist Methorismus.
Blähungen, die Luft ist im Bauch, im Darum.
Das ist ein Geblähtenbauch.
Ich fühle mich sehr gut.
Flatulenz ist das, dass die Gas aus dem Wasser geht.
Blähungen sind Gasdol.
Wenn man die Gas in die Karre verholt,
ist das Flatulenz, die Gas weggeht.
Und Furkan hat nicht gefragt,
geht ein Wind ab.
Genau, hat nicht gefragt.
Deswegen, das sind Ehungen, keine Flatulenz.
Und die Vegetative am Nese ist unauffällig
bis auf eine Inappetenz.
Und die Fragen nach Defekation und Mixionproblemen,
Gewichtsveränderungen und Geschlechts-Sexuellproblemen
wurden von der Patientin verneint.
Es sei keine relevant.
Sie hat keine Übelkeit, sie hat keine Erbrechene,
aber leichte Übelkeit.
Das wäre die zweite Frage später.
Und da habe ich mich selbst ein bisschen falsch erinnert.
Meinte, leicht übergegelt hat sie.
Und in der Vegetative am Nese
hat Schmerzbedingte, Insomnia und Inappetenz.
Ja, aber sie hat, ich ...
2 Tage, 2 Tage Inappetenz.
2 Tage Inappetenz und Insomnia.
Schmerzbedingte.
Genau, sie ist in der Nacht wegen Schmerz in Wach geworden.
Und das wäre, hat Schmerzbedingte, ja,
gut Schlaflosigkeit, genau, das kann man schon sagen.
Und es seien keine relevanten Vorerkrankungen,
weil ihr bekannt, man im Besuch auf die Medikation,
nehme Frau Geist, keine Medikamente regelmäßig ein.
Sie habe eine Polynosis, die durch Laufendenase
und Augentrainer aussahe.
Sie sei nicht Traukerin
und trinken nur bei der Feier ein Glas Wein.
Das ist gelegentlich sozusagen.
Gelegentlich.
Und sie habe als Studentin ein paar Mal Extasy und Marihuana probiert.
Bei der Sportanamnese
fanden sich Yoga, Fitness und Porreball.
Und sie habe, ja, sie sind, sie sei alleine.
Und habe keine Kinder und beschäftige als Geschäftsführerin
in kleinen Firmen aktuell.
Und ihre Eltern leben noch und hätten keine Probleme.
Und sie habe einen Bruder, der an Artelipotoni leidet.
Ja, die anamnistische Angabe der Namen Ehesten
auf eine, also Obstipation vielleicht.
Wie sind die Laborwerte?
Ja, CHP ist erhöht und Linkpostalsschmerzen,
Rente unter.
Stopp, das CHP.
160.
Ist das hoch oder nicht hoch?
Wie sehen Sie das?
Ja, es ist hoch aus meiner Sicht.
Aber es gibt keine Leukocytose.
Keine Leukocytose.
Ja, Sie haben eine Mitte.
Sie hat ein sehr hohes CHP.
160 ist schon ein hoch.
Und Sie hat Schmerzen im rechten Unterbau, haben Sie gesagt,
Sie haben beide Untersuchungen.
Und Sie sagen, dass Ihre Verdachtsschmerzen Obstipation.
Was ist noch?
Ja, als die Fernseher Diagnose kommen, die folgen dem Betracht.
Also abends ist natürlich, also Sie haben in der rechten Unterbauch
ein Druckgefühl.
Dort gibt es Landspunkte, also kontr-laterale Loslastschmerzen.
Und natürlich bei der linke Unterbauch, wenn eine,
wenn in der linke Unterbauch gibt es ein Loslastschmerzen,
denken wir, so sollte immer ein Appendicitis gedankt werden.
Was würden Sie für eine Untersuchung noch machen wollen
und sicher eine Appendicitis auszukaufen oder zu bestätigen
für eine jungen Frau?
Also als erstes würde ich eine Ultraschall durchführen.
Okay, im Ultraschall?
Wie bitte?
Im Ultraschall, das hat sie gemacht, da hat mir nichts erkannt.
Nichts gesehen.
Ja, dann, wir haben schon, ich glaube, ein Röntgen durchgeführt.
Also, ja.
Nur Blähung.
Was würden Sie noch?
Ja, Kompetentomographie könnte veranlasst werden.
Oder?
Ja, oder ja, Kolonoscopy vielleicht.
Aber...
Bei einer jungen Frau würde man auch ein MRT, ein Kernspin machen, ne?
Ja, ich habe es gefragt, also sie habe keine Probleme mit Geschlechtswerke,
aber sie haben auch keinen Partner.
Ja, ja, aber warum MRT statt Kompetentomographie?
Das ist noch eine junge Frau, keine Straße.
Ja, ich habe es vergessen, könnte es sein,
dass ich schwanger sind, sollte ich fragen.
Ja, aber nicht nur wegen der Schwangerschaft,
sondern die Option und die Möglichkeit haben,
eine Kernspin-Tomographie zu machen, dann ist es natürlich besser
für eine junge Frau, weil dann hat sich keine Strahlenbelastung.
Ja, natürlich.
Und wir sind ein großes Krankenhaus, und wir haben diese Möglichkeit,
also würde man eher eine Kernspin-Tomographie
bei einer jungen Frau oder bei einem Kind durchführen,
statt einem zu gehen.
Wenn wir die Möglichkeit nicht hätten,
dann würde man natürlich auch ein Kompetentomographie machen.
Diese würde die Diagnose, ob eine Appendicitis vorliegt oder nicht,
sicherlich genauer mitteilen.
Okay, das heißt, was haben Sie noch für die weitere Differenzialdiagnosen,
außer Appendicitis?
Ja, also ich dachte,
ich dachte, Ausstülpung des Wandarms, also die Vertikulitis vielleicht,
kann es sein.
Rechter Unterbauch, die Vertikulitis, also der linker Unterbauch.
Der linker Unterbauch eher nicht, da ist keine Diagnose.
Ja, Eleus vielleicht.
Was? Ein Eleus?
Mechanische Eleus.
Eine Ausstülpung vom Darm, nennt man was?
Ein Leistenbruch.
Ja, ein Leistenbruch, ja.
Aber es gibt keine brennende Schmerzen,
deswegen habe ich nicht gedacht.
Die Differenzialdiagnosen, okay.
Sie haben ja schon Ihre Vermutung, Ihre Arbeitsdiagnose
bzw. Ihre Verdachtdiagnose haben Sie schon gesagt,
Sie gehen von einer Obstipation aus.
Und wir reden jetzt über die Differenzialdiagnosen.
Weiche Möglichkeiten kommen in Betracht.
Und Sie haben jetzt als weitere Möglichkeit genannt,
eine Appendicitis, ein Eleus, eine Divertikulitis,
was nicht ganz korrekt ist, weitere Differenzialdiagnosen.
Oberdiathorsion.
Stopp, der Kollege Badan sollte es sagen.
Ja, ich habe es gedacht.
Aber es gibt keine Ergebnisse dafür bei der Ultraschall.
Okay, welche Differenzialdiagnose müssen Sie noch denken?
Ja, Schwangeschafft.
Natürlich kann es sein.
Sistitis kann es sein auch.
Sistitis, genau.
Ich habe die Kollegen ein paar Hilfe gegeben.
No Agastroenteritis, vielleicht aber es gibt eine Artnexitis.
Artnexitis, genau.
Herr Kollege, ich habe dich heute sehr schlussiert.
Du hast eine Krise geblieben.
Es ist eine Art Krise.
Es ist keine Sorge, Herr Kollege.
Aber ich habe es heute für dich geblieben.
Ich habe es heute für dich geblieben.